[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe there's no stopping
us right now i feel so close to you
hey baby
[Music]
how you doing good i'm doing so good you
want to talk about bitcoin
well one thing is people love when we
spend one episode on a topic
religion bitcoin yeah but you gotta
understand we're going off the cuff
in every single episode you come you
come in we sit down we turn on
we don't know where we're going to go
it's part of watching something you want
to watch a topic
sometimes you're going to get a million
topics dude and here's the thing
we are we're starting to think now like
when women's periods sync up
our brains are starting to sync up sure
because we're both wearing mike tyson
stuff
look at this you came in today and i was
like dude are you kidding me i got a
mike tyson christmas sweater on
and i got the uh punch out my test this
is a very
very different mike tyson yeah and i'm
i'm going festive three months later i
love it
yeah even though even though you know
people think we bank 25 episodes
uh in a row um we don't with that being
said
just want to give a quick before we
start off anything quick shout out
tampa buckingham tampa bay bucks just
won the super bowl shout out tom brady
actually shout out tom brady oldest
player in the nfl
first time the super bowl was in the
hometown of the per
the team in the super bowl football and
then we'd be remiss to say because you
know it's
want to also give a shout out to kansas
city chiefs 100 percent got it
check my homes from homes great kids did
a noble job they have a bright future
ahead of them patrick mahomes best
looking guy in the nfl
he's got beautiful hair gorgeous hair
right i killed for his hair i'd kill for
his hair well you've got great hair too
salad
yeah it depends on the day but thanks
yeah i think it's got good hair
i saw my first gray like my first grade
the other day
really i have a question do you
understand do you understand how gray
hair works
like in other words you ever like not
see a gray at all then all of a sudden
there's a gray
dead smack in the middle like did that
turn gray
overnight or did it start growing out of
the follicle gray
and i didn't notice for the last three
months you know what it's a good point
never thought about it but i'll tell you
what happens to me is once in a while i
get a mystery
red-haired pubic hair yeah do you ever
get a red pup i get all colors in my
beard how though
not in my not in my pubes but it might
be here isn't pubes
pubes is a gross word it's the worst
word ever pubic it is
it is so bad like it's totally
it's totally pink bring that fact back
up you said in fact hair doesn't
actually turn gray at all
i thought i thought it said hair doesn't
actually turn gay at all so you could be
gay but your hair will not be
once a hair follicle produces hair the
color is set if a single strand of hair
starts out brown or red or black or
blonde
it is never going to change color unless
you color your hair so then
what i can see so am i do that didn't
make any sense yeah do i
do i am i color blind then like does my
eyes start to see different colors
because
people have gray hair yeah people are
great and i've heard stories and
and tell me if you've heard this but
i've heard stories where people wake up
like and all of a sudden they're gray
like they have a dramatic experience or
something weird happens
and and a switch is flipped and then
they wake up and they have like their
hair goes but maybe this is like a
really rare crazy thing i mean i heard
like they wake up and they have white
hair right maybe i don't know i saw
brian regan the great comedian brian
regan
i saw him like a week before the
pandemic and then he comes out and does
his special on netflix called on the
rocks which i think is one of bro i love
brian regan but i think this is
one of the best one of the best uh uh
specials i've seen in a long time so
good so clean but his hair is fully gray
yeah his hair went full gray he
addresses it i i actually i've always
have high hopes for his specialist
i watched it and he had me laughing out
loud yeah completely clean
completely clean special um this is a
completely clean podcast yeah you could
do it
you could do it these days you could
just do whatever we want we're doing a
completely clean podcast even though i
know that upsets some people
this isn't even completely clean
whatsoever yeah we curse
whatever we want we just said maybe in
the beginning we're like should we curse
we we
knew we want sponsors we didn't really
know how it worked yeah so we're like
well if we curse a whole bunch let's
let's take some of them out
and then he then pimped that's a funny
idea to throw in a hey hey babe and we
thought that was really funny and we
kind of rolled with it
but curses we're not trying not to
really curse well
the thing is though the thing is though
after even watching brian reagan's
especially i've heard brian reagan talk
about this
and jerry seinfeld talked about this it
is so
hard to try to be funny for an hour and
not curse once in today's day in the
world and so for me
i like it as the challenge because i got
my other podcast chrissy chaos
where i come right out of the gate yeah
you know cursing up the store
you say you just like what's up hey babe
yeah 100
that's what i do i started out yeah i
get i i'm i'm going wild on that one
but this one i think that it's so you
can go wild on this one too
no we go no no no no no no no no the
thing is we're going wild on this one we
go wild but we're going back wild but we
are not
it's so much harder because you got to
just you know like
come up with things that are like you
know fun and easy to talk about
and and just the vibe it's not the best
what we're going for with the vibe
overall because we wanted to like all
right how there's so many podcasts out
there
yeah we're just like all right what what
is missing i just feel like you know i
just i just like to come on just have
like a
yeah this is a podcast my mother can
listen to which is this is this is
actually
this is some of my comedy that my mother
does listen to which is a rarity from my
mom
she will never listen to anything else i
do but hey babe
by the way how about this i was opening
up the i was opening up the mail
yesterday okay
okay i got to go back to gray's i don't
want to forget i was opening up the mail
yesterday
i'm genuinely opening this thing up i
get this flag
it's black and white i start to open it
up
and i'm literally thought that you as a
prank sent me an isis flag
that's what i thought was the was the
bit funny prank i was like oh
he he hey babe it was i would always say
hey bae you got hay babe with an isis
flap
what is it look at what this thing is
look at this
it's upside down wait manscaped
they sent you a flag manscaped
you know thanks but the balls on you
guys
to think somebody wants a six-foot
banner
that that i mean what do you do with
that dude i get it i
look look i get it it's a tchotchke it's
a marketing materials
it's promotional it's beautiful but but
what are you going to do with a six-foot
banner that says your balls will thank
you man
it was one of those things where my
girlfriend said when i opened it up
she said please get that out of my house
and take it to sales
you know what i'm trying to say they're
patriots yeah i'm just saying but you
remember how everybody was like flagged
crazy after that yes and then people
were just
draping bananas or banners off of their
homes yeah that's basically
what could you do with that i guess if
you're if you're clean if you're
if you're selling if you're moving a lot
of manscape you get the banner so we
want to say thank you to manscape
thank you you can wrap yourself in that
that could be like an answer out of the
shower towel around you 100
oh yeah no my daughter's goes crazy for
something like that landscape
any type of big object oh i see what
you're saying it's just like a
it's a big piece of material she's not
going crazy she can make a cape a brooch
whatever imagine she's a five-year-old
girl imagine her favorite product was
manscaped she was like dad the lawnmower
3.0
you don't know about i love the lord 3.0
the 2.0 i was even born
no dude speaking of that so i'm going
i'm going to california for two minutes
like led zeppelin
yeah do you know what that means you
don't even know what happened no going
to california was an aitkin
in my it's a song from zeppelin shout
out led zeppelin going to california
yeah no yeah
isn't that off uh houses of the holy
maybe let's see how good
i know one led zeppelin song you know
every one of them but i just don't know
that it's like
they have eight album nine albums you
know a lot of their songs are they
american
california going to california led
zeppelin no i don't know this song
i don't know but i'm going to california
mine would be biggie i'm going going
back back to cali yo big big 504 fly
504.
that's the beginning when he's like
waking up
[Laughter]
yeah oh cali he says biggie would wiggy
would have been
a uh pretty much dead ringer for covet i
think i think biggie would have got
covered
i think biggie i think biggie cove he's
like what covert wants to eat was in
biggie's body
so you know but his name's biggie his
name is
taking targets people like i think they
say high risk for uh obese
because you don't know because maybe if
biggie would have kept living you know
he might have got thin big he keeps well
he would
have you never know you would when a
keto wasn't even invented back then yeah
i picked
imagine could you picture what big he
would look like if he was
half his weight no i no i don't know
yeah i don't know no i i don't i don't
want to think about that i
like thinking about heavy voice is
better than biggie's voice
who's
i think the only rival voice sounded
like him at least
the only rival voice and i'm not and if
we're talking about just music
i think you know his rap like when when
the biggest one comes on you know it's
biggie but the only
rival voice in general you're like whoa
you have to stop everything you're doing
and listen to this guy's voice
is james earl jones james earl jones
shout out mustafa
is the only is the only other guy that
i'm like wow his voice is crazy did you
see coming to america too yet
i did you did yeah well you know what it
is it's like they had to
it really became something else like the
cameos
unbelievable like i think they got every
last person back
who could come back so that was great
and there was some really funny moments
but it was pretty long and it
it didn't exactly have the same tone as
the first one right you know eddie
murphy drove it the first one he had
this like
like like this naive that this naivete
that he
like that was the word naivete that's
very charming right you know he was
aloof a little bit and you kind of
but he in this one the whole conceit is
that he is
a little bit more like uh jaded and so
you he pulls it pulls away from like
what you loved about the first one you
know what i mean
what about this name for a loofah
company a loofah
a loofah well how cause it has luff in
it already because you're a loof
but a loofah i'm a loser
yeah i mean you don't love it i don't
love it only because
aloof let me ask you this definition
doesn't really have much to do with a
loofah
can i ask you this put you on and you
have to say and you have to just give me
an answer you can't think about it
what do you like better aloofa or coming
to america too
oh i'm gonna say aloof
wow oh wait you mean aloofa or aloofa
your company
i'm talking about a loofah my idea for
the company or coming to america too you
have to pick one
one stays one ghost i'll take coming to
america and it's no offense to you but
one is a
a movie based around entertainment and
one is just a haphazard idea you threw
out me 10 seconds ago
i have a question for you don't you feel
like all sequels are cursed
yes uh for the most part sequels are
tougher right
the best the only boys which you didn't
see at all i didn't see any of them
terminated two
terminator two the future two was pretty
good back to feature two was good i also
thought wayne's world two was good
wayne's world two was good
but i but the dumb and dumber sequel was
not good uh the one without them or with
them the one with them
i i didn't think the one with them was
great and dumb and you have to
understand
but here's the thing task at hand is
measurable it's the same with coming to
america though i'd argue the task at
hand with trying to remake coming to
america is
coming to america is a monumental movie
dumb and dumb and monumental movies and
i
dumb and dumber was my favorite movie of
all time i
love love so i think when i watched the
second one i was like just thinking
about the first one
yeah it's almost like a thing like in
retrospect you should never do
a sequel yeah well you know what it is
it's like i don't know when
when i heard it was coming to america's
sequel sequel i was it's one of my
favorite movies of all time right so
i was ecstatic but nervous right and
then you know you but don't get me wrong
like it was it was really what's his
name um
oh my god i don't want to forget his
actual name but mcdowell's um
uh how do i uh hall no or
no um jermaine fowler good times no no
no um
his father-in-law i i mean i know his
name so well i just
did he pass away no no no he's he's the
owner of mcdowell's oh mcdowell right
uh right if we go to cast there we go oh
leslie jones is in it tracy morgan great
cast
john amos yeah oh yeah they had
everybody in there right wesley snipes
is like the villain
i mean they had some really good cameos
it was it was it was fun
they had i mean they even got people
back like not even main characters they
got like
small characters back too that part was
really awesome
and some people hit home runs for sure
but overall
do you have to see coming america one to
understand coming america too
you will you will miss out you don't
have you don't have to they kind of
but you will miss out on about no joke
maybe 50 references
right maybe more the whole like a lot of
it's references because like what is
even the premise like
he's already in like he's just coming
back to america no spoiler alert if i
could help it
he he lives in zamunda now he's
he's becoming the king right right he's
about to become the king right
from his dad he's married to lisa still
from the first one they have three
girls so there's no one there's no man
to take the throne from him
he finds out he fathered a child when he
was in queens that time who's jermaine
fowler who's jermaine fowler right and
he goes back to get your main bring him
back to the kingdom and have him take
over that's a good premise yeah it's
pretty good actually yeah that's a good
it's a good i get it it's good so it
really shouldn't be called coming to
america should be called going to
zamunda
yeah that should have been the name yeah
zamunda would have been that
fictional i also heard that they filmed
all the scenes
in the castle of zamunda in rick ross's
house
really yeah does rick ross have a pretty
nice crib maybe the interior because
the exterior looked like it was like
kind of fake like cgi it was like a
yeah i mean it was like like it looked
like a taj mahal yes but inside i read
an article that said the
in inside was rick ross's dude by the
way the best
uh the best sequel of all time in my
opinion is indiana jones temple of doom
that's an amazing
that's kalima shakti day my uncle johnny
used to go kalima
shakti day when he used to like rip his
hand out of it put his hand in the guy's
chest and rip his heart and my uncle
would say
when i would sleep over his house
because you know his his daughters were
my first cousin we would have sleepovers
and i would never want to go to sleep
and he would come to me and be like
if you don't go to sleep on shakti day
and i remember being like
like you know just being huh but like
genuinely terrified
inside and telling my mom like yeah like
telling my mom like it's very hard for
me to sleep there because i think uncle
johnny's going to rip my heart out
it's like that nervous laughter in good
fellas where he's like uh
what am i clown
yeah i um yeah dude and so i'm gonna
we're gonna get back to gray harris i'm
going to la yeah yeah for two months
yeah the task and i'm going with my
family
the task to pack is so monumental for me
so what i've decided to do is only go
because
because now i'm thinking about checking
seven luggages the kid's luggage her
luggage my luggage
i said it's tough traveling with uh baby
too smile
children it's so tough she's six months
pregnant i've decided on my end
she can pack for the kids whatever the
kids want i can hold a little elsa's
suitcase and a little ninja turtle
suitcase
and her thing for me rather than just
everybody's going everybody's going wow
yeah so so it's me
it's me my girl my daughter and my
stepson we're all going out there
for two months so so so i made this
decision this morning and this is what i
will do
the task has been so monumental yeah for
me to think about packing this doing
this doing that
i'm bringing a book bag with all the
socks and underwear i have
a bathing suit a couple of t-shirts and
some shorts that i can all fit in a book
bag
and that is it everything else that i
get in los angeles
i will buy when i get to los angeles i
will go
i will show up to the to the set of the
show the very first day with the
lululemon pants on that i always travel
with shout out lulu used to be double xl
now my skinny mini ass is getting
slightly into an xl
but it still busts at the seams so for
maximum comfort on the flight i will do
double xl yeah a black champion
sweatshirt because i'm chrissy champions
my patagonia jacket because it folds up
and can the uniform for travel you know
it can consolidate into anywhere
uh uh glasses because i don't want to
get covered in my eye
yep and my mask and that is it and that
is it i got some extra shields i'm going
to take your shield yeah
i'm going to uh i'm going so that's what
i'm going to do
jasmine says that it's ridiculous i'm
just going to go
because when do you start when do you
start filming i land i land and i gotta
i gotta start the next day but i'm
thinking you gotta bring one pair of
dungarees
maybe i'll wear these then you gotta you
gotta bring one pair of dungarees you
don't wanna have to run but i'm talking
about sneakers
i'm gonna have one pair i'm gonna have
the sneaker the sneakers that i want to
mostly wear
yeah the um uh i have a pair of jordan
ones like that are cool like
you know like blue white and black
neutral colors i'm gonna wear those and
then
and then just just not bring anything
else but then you
you give yourself the task when you get
out there of having to
leave and go buy are they giving your
wardrobe no
because first season no wardrobe
department so i kind of said like i'll
go because here's what i want to do
here's what i want to try to live and i
want to try this figure i'm going to la
i've been watching a lot of
documentaries on buddhism i've been
meditating a lot i've been trying to eat
cleaner
i'm going to try to live for the first
time
beneath you know within my means but not
have a lot of
not have a lot of possessions just kind
of live with the clothes on my back
minimalist
minimalist i want to i want to go
chrissy minimalist i like that
i'm going to try to do it's hard to do
but i'm going to try yeah it's all you
need though you'll join
us right away how long do you think
though how many days am i gonna last
night do you think by day three
i'm fully in the mall texting you like
dude i just spent a thousand dollars on
new clothes
you're gonna have to buy clothes right
because let me ask you this how many
um do you film a full episode in one day
no right so
now there's all the continuity things so
if you're filming over multiple days you
have to have that outfit
and we're filming two episodes at once i
hate this apple watch by the way is it
new
i just got it yesterday and to track my
calories but now it's constantly people
are calling me
and it just keeps vibrating on my wrist
you didn't get you didn't get in there
and turn off notice i don't know how to
do anything because it's a washer it's
got a little face you also have that
thing where you didn't put it secure
enough so the watches
this is like i hate when it happens when
the watch goes over here yeah because i
because i tried to have it one thing
tighter and i felt like it was cutting
off circulation to my fingers
when you do it with a belt it's the
worst i don't have a good hat and i
don't have a good wrist watch
yeah you don't have a good watch wrist
watch
wrist
[Laughter]
my wrist mom this is crazy right now so
and if you go
too tight it's too easy i
you got to lose a little more weight on
your wrist or gain weight on your wrist
i got i'm going to try to lose weight on
the wrist but i will tell you this what
makes it very easy it's 39 degrees right
now
and it's monday and it's monday march
8th despite what you think you
you'll never not have the date and
weather at your fingertips
i don't i can't that's too much for me
right it's too much
i'll tell you a couple of reasons one
i'm a person who
lives in constant fear of a drained
battery in
all facets i'm afraid of it not even in
my laptop and my phone i'm afraid of it
in my remotes
everything like anything and everything
you never know when the bat especially
in
in something like a remote yeah all of a
sudden it's just dead and if you're not
prepared with the battery you're done
do you know that i travel with two
double a's and two
aaa batteries lest i arrive at a hotel
in the middle of nowhere
and the batteries suck because it
happens more
we should seriously do a game we should
seriously do a game
and put two blank pieces to put two
pieces of paper
write all the traits uh all the all the
the little
quirkiness things of idiosyncratic
idiosyncrasies
of sal and then write all the
idiosyncrasies of a known convicted
serial killer
and pick which one is sal which one is
charles manson
yes he goes with two double a's yes
i do i think he's also he's also
twisting the corners he can't have
corners pointed out
the more you
because i actually but no but actually
you know where you're getting help at
betterhelp.com
sorry promo code hey babe we're not even
there yet promo code
does that count oh yeah that was it that
was
do you think that do you really think
that i exhibit uh
characteristics of a serial killer there
or do you think that i'm a smart
efficient traveler
who understands how to uh to to
uh to to to uh anticipate
potential issues that can be big
problems but solve them
in a small way it doesn't take a lot you
know what i do i put the four batteries
in my luggage in a permanent pocket i
never touch it ever again i know it's
there
whenever i get to and guess what you
know what the best feeling in the world
is
going to a hotel checking in going up
there going like this
and the batteries in their motor on the
fritz and i just
i i just i just i usually walk over to
the mirror
and i just watch myself smile a little
bit and i go like something like that
and then i walk over i take it out i put
the new batteries in
so i have to be honest with you i've
checked in and out of i want to say
in my life a thousand hotels never once
never once has the battery not worked
and if it didn't work
i would simply press zero on the phone
and ask someone to come
up with batteries and replace can i tell
you my experience okay
my experience it's happened maybe once
or twice only but that's all it takes
for me
also if i get there like one in the
morning or two in the morning
right and i'm just like i want the
problem fixed now right yeah another
thing is like sometimes i'll call down
because another thing the first thing i
do when i get to a hotel the first thing
i do
i check that the air is working
correctly right and then i also
immediately call down
for three to four extra pillows okay
immediately i want them to be brought up
right away i don't wanna i don't wanna
wait until i'm
tired right and go into bed and i forgot
to call them and then
the guy at the night shift takes his
sweet ass time because what's he doing
down there
he's playing whatever those you know
he's playing you know minecraft or or
solitaire or something he's like one of
those yeah yeah and so and that
and that really grinds my gear so when i
when i call and they take like an
hour to come and sometimes i call again
i'm like hey
i uh i i'm i'm you know 2 16 room 269
cold about 40 minutes ago first three
pillows
oh yeah yeah well we'll get there and
i'm just like oh you'll get here really
because it's like i'm getting tired and
it's like
you just have to bring up a p you know
like i'll come down i'll come down i'll
come down and get it
so i just don't want that so if i you
know the the batteries don't weigh much
right and then i and then i know they
don't it's really that's not like it's
cumbersome no listen like i'm bringing
sometimes i bring my own pillow to a
hotel really yeah
and what's the reason i go airbnb or my
own pillows you won't use their stuff
no but what about taking like would you
you don't mind
carrying up checking that or you get it
all and carry on let me clarify um if i
do uh if i drive to an airbnb
okay if you drive a family vacation or
something where i might send like a
little house or something
up in the poconos or long island or
wherever it like i'll bring all my own
linens and sheets and come from that
i can understand but like i'd rather
when i'm getting on a flight
i'm all about being minimal i i don't
know why
even though i know it's like i need the
stuff i genuinely rather
not have the things i want for two
months than just pack it and try to
stick it in a in an overhead or have to
go
get chuck check uh luggage for you know
even though i'd rather too much then 20
minutes of inconvenience yeah but
jazz is going to check bags so now
you're screwed you've got to go to the
check bag
i'm trying to get her to just live
minimally too i'm saying listen what do
we need here
but it's not going to work with two kids
and a woman no it's not going to work
it's not going to work but if she's
checking you should just check how about
this ever tell you about this story
hotels by the way little little uh psa
here when you're in a hotel
you have to not only lock the door but
lock that bolt lock on the door
everyone in the hotel knocks and walks
right in
they can have your key no no ev people
have your key
i was in the hotel room with jasmine
recently
i won't say works i wanted to get in
trouble but whatever i was in the hotel
room with jasmine
three o'clock in the morning somebody
tried to open our door
from the hotel st it had to be from the
hotel staff but i had the bolt lock on
so i woke up and i was like hello and
then
i i go to uh uh open the door
you know i see through the people it's a
it's a like a maintenance sky
with the hotel he's like oh i'm sorry
did you guys call for your air
conditioner to be serviced and we were
like i was like
no three in the morning three in the
morning suspect just tried to open up so
i'm thinking was this creep
did he see jasmine at some point know
what room she's in somehow because i
said
hey did you like tell anyone your room
was like at the front desk and she's
severe severe but then i i i
brought it up and people have said i'm
telling you i guarantee you there's
somebody out there listening it's like
that happened to them so you have to
bolt lock your hotel room door you
cannot
just lock it what hotel because people
have to beat it i need to know
what hotel was it yeah we could be we
could
really wow that's a known brand
known brand i thought you were going to
say something like i didn't know no same
thing with the airbnb we're staying at
airbnb but make no
if there is no bolt lock you know what i
actually may bring with me
i have a bolt lock and i'm going to
bring it with me i should wait out here
i swear to god i'm going to bring a
bullet
i won't bring pants but i'll bring them
all in i got one of those sliding glass
doors i like to drop a little stick in
there
so that it's impossible because those
doors are always broken too
terrorists and stuff they never work you
just you flip the thing and you go like
it just open
i spent i've probably spent cumulatively
stroke cumulatively in hotels i probably
spent like hours
going like is this not walking and then
i twist it and then
the thing goes right and then i and i
pull it and you see the thing and you're
like
the hook and you're like oh it's kind of
clicking in and i lift the door up and i
push it and then i click it i try to
catch it doesn't catch
and then i'm like i gotta go to like
home depot and buy like a dowel
right and drop it in there it's
basically going to lock the the thing
now how many hotels have you stormed out
of because of they're just terrible
i actually have stormed out of hotels
you've shown that a hotel oh yes i have
really yes there was a uh uh i wish i
remembered the name of it
crown something or other uh we pulled up
to this hotel
i will say bus tours i bring all my own
linens and
pillows yeah cause you're on the bus
yeah i get it but we also check into
hotels one time we got to this hotel
right now i'm not gonna remember where
it was uh but went up to my room
and i sat down on the couch and i'm just
looking around like
this i see big dust bunnies all over the
floor then i look a little closer there
was like
needles on the floor not like needles
like syringes like needles like sewing
needles
okay like all over the floor i could
have stepped on and then i'm like
i look at the table and i see hair on
the table and then i
and you know when you like go like this
and you see like the light hits the
table
and the table had a wood like
shellacking on it right but you could
see all the fingerprints and grease from
other people's food
and i look and i see all this grease and
crumbs and hair on the table i'm like
what the hell
and i get up and go go in the bathroom
hair in the sink there was a bull and
then
the topper of all toppers there was
blood there was like
red it could be smeared blood
on one of the like on one of the end
tables i walked right downstairs i told
them cancel
i told told the guys and everything
canceled every single reservation we
have i never seen anything like this in
my life and we went to another hotel
but who who else wouldn't do that what
did they say all right today's episode
is brought to you by
peek a super advanced plant-based
supplement company pete combines the
finest ingredients with cutting edge
technology to create ultra effective and
high quality supplements for your body
now i've actually taken it upside down
sorry
i've i've actually taken this this is
awesome because you know when you take
vitamins and there's vitamin c and you
pee is like neon green yes that's
because your body's not absorbing the
vitamins
you're really not getting like the most
out of it peak i've
never i've taken a peekaboo at my uh my
peepee and i've
it's never been neon greedy i've taken
this so that means my body's absorbing
all the vitamin c and i even went to the
doctor and got blood tests they said my
vitamin c is at
fantastic levels yeah so this is it's
also cool because it's on the go and i
know like
my uh i have like my sister for example
she cannot swallow vitamins can't do it
like you just get no matter how much
water it's like a problem swallowing so
what they do is they make it into this
little tasty little like
squeeze packet yeah it's a little yeah
and you can take it on the go you don't
even need water dude i love it
i'm gonna take it right now but a peak t
p i
q u e t t e a dot com
slash hey babe and use the code hey babe
at checkout
and you get five percent off so that's p
i q u e
t e a dot com slash hey babe use the
promo code hey babe
five percent off your first order plus
free shipping when you purchase a bundle
and i'm telling you this is so worth it
because everybody needs vitamin c
everyone needs their vitamins and
um you know a lot of times it doesn't
get absorbed this is so gentle on my
stomach i've never had a tummy ache
i just take this and it feels good and
you know what i like about it is it
opens like a little package like this
and it makes me think of ketchup so
sometimes i put it on my egg and cheese
sandwich
did you just take adderall
you look like a little kid who just got
like a riddle uh
you really went off on a tangent though
no i just said i took it so right now i
have a thousand milligrams of vitamin c
absorbing into my cells where they
should be not my pee
no no it tastes good fantastic flavor
it's really nice
i love it daily immune is flying off the
shelves people are ordering more than
two so you got to stock up
um there's a reason pique has over 15
000 five star reviews people it's gonna
have 15 000 won because i'm giving it a
five star
and what i love what companies do this
30-day satisfaction guarantee
either you love it or you get your money
back so there's really nothing to lose
p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a dot com slash hey babe
use the code hey babe five percent off
plus free shipping on a bundle
put it on your egg sandwiches you'll
thank me chris yeah can you please tell
me
if you know of any place that i can go
if i want to get a little bit of
discreet counseling
off the top of my head the number one
place that i
i'm thinking of is betterhelp.com
well what's that i gotta go to some
office no what's that i gotta pay
outrageous prices
nope well i gotta wait two weeks to
start it nope you can do it from the
comfort of your own home
get a discreet licensed counselor
to hear whatever it is you want to talk
about for a great price
if you put in the promo code hey babe
you actually get 10 off the first month
10
off american go to 10 as far as i'm as
far as i know
i was told 10 american money wherever
you could be in islamabad pakistan right
you're still going to get off 10
american for the first month by going to
better help
not health better help help
calm promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
10 off the first month it's just it's
the right thing to do
i can't believe i asked you that because
you had all the information i needed
sal a lot of times i'll see you doing
things
and i'll say why don't you just ask me
yeah and i'm happy that
on the podcast you decided to ask me
remember that time i was just putting a
straw into an orange and you were like
you should just pour yourself a glass of
juice
yes i should defer to you more often and
where do you think because
like i was just like you how many times
did you see me
putting the straw into the orange a lot
how did i learn
to start drinking orange juice
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com is why i learned that you
don't have to do that it's just in the
commercial
do they stick the straw in the orange
juice you don't want to make sense
because we could all
use betterhelp dot com
backslash hey babe for 10 off who
doesn't want 10
off the first month of anything i want
10 percent off everything they're
getting me spoiled
yeah better help is getting me spoiled
yeah i storm into a room now the first
thing i say is i want 10 percent off i
want to
kill where i am yeah if they come to
back to this show and they want to
advertise and say we love your fan so
much
they've been they've been supporting
betterhelp.com hey babe so much we want
to give you 20 off i'm going to say no
it's going to stay at 10.
that's right it just feels right you're
not trying to take advantage
it just feels right betterhelp.com hey
babe
when you did they apologized and they
said they would clean it and try it and
i was like
no no there's nothing i mean this blood
needles hair
and was just like a nice hotel it was
like a like a
like a yes yes it wasn't like a five
star but it was like you know you
weren't staying in like a freaking off
the side of the highway motel town plaza
thing yeah i think is that the is in
chicago
it might have been yeah yeah by the
airport west yeah
there's a lot of them i don't know which
one it was yeah crown plaza it was a
crown plaza
yeah by the airports i'm not coming down
on all crown plazas but not one on that
day
you got problems no bueno yeah yeah dude
but you know what man
speaking of break-ins too it made me
think you got to be careful whose house
you break into or who you rob any
criminals out there who are listening
did i ever tell you about the story of
what happened when somebody robbed my
mother by
i got the story for you too right after
this my house got robbed while i was in
it we're gonna go back to back yeah go
back to back right now
i got yeah so my uncle victor r.i.p
r.i.p love you uh
somebody was there was a a ring going
around somebody was somebody was robbing
like women's purses in my neighborhood
oh there was a crime rate
crime ring going around going around
robbing women's purses right in my
neighborhood
so off of the women in the street like
ripping them off their shoulder right
and then you know muggings
right and then selling or you know
the the the ring the criminal enterprise
ring was was being
dealt with out of the back of a bodega
that was on my corner so the back of the
bodega
on my corner it was a hot spot they were
stealing bags and they you know money
selling whatever did you know this let
me tell you okay
so my uncle my uncle used to hang out
all the time in this bodega and i had
credit at the bodega because they knew
that i was his his nephew through
marriage so i go in there
get you know a cheese you know sandwich
and soda i'd say put this on uncle
victor's tab and they would say okay
because they knew they knew that he's
good for it because i'm on victor's ki
i'm victor's uh you know uh nephew
through marriage so they were like it's
all good okay so then one time so
they were like okay okay i'm reloaded
you know
you selling scarface yeah it was the
yeah so it was the guys in the bodegas
so
one day somebody steals my mother's
purse
off the shoulder my mother pushes oh my
god pushes my own mother to the ground
steals her mug steals her purse she got
mugged shows up to the house
hands bleeding from from being thrown to
the floor oh
yeah god that's bad bag ripped off the
shoulder my mother did manage then this
one was shot on my mom she did manage
shout out she had her uh purse on her
left shoulder she had
our dinner which was uh uh from wendy's
in her right hand she dropped the soda
but she was able to keep my chicken
nuggets and a small cheeseburger oh god
and served it to me and it's
unbelievable i didn't get the frosty
that i wanted but shout out to
you shout out chilly day it's a nice
chili on that one my mom still that's
how you know and you know that's how you
know like and by the way today is
international women's day whenever this
episode comes out so i just want to give
a shout out to my mother
is is you you i'll never forget that you
did feed me that night even though you
just got mugged you saved the wendy's
you sacrificed your purse but you said
you're not one thing you're not getting
is my son's chicken nuggets with a small
fry no no no you're not getting that
chicken nugget is a small fry for all
purposes to you
way more valuable than her purse yeah i
was like mom i don't care that you lost
your social security card that means
nothing to me i'm not
i was gonna say i was gonna say was she
like did she handle it was she like this
[ __ ] grabbed my thing and ran i
screamed but i couldn't
wish did she go home like oh she came
out to stay indoors
for the next five years it was one of
those things she was like i just i just
was mugged
somebody stole my purse and then my my
aunt who we live and she's like
call 9-1-1 you know whatever and then
and then i was like oh my god what
happened and then my mom has the wendy's
and she's like here i have your dinner
so so i'm like ugh so i'm eating
yeah i'm like mom you you the barbecue
sauce you know i want extra
you know how good wendy's barbecue sauce
is and two sauces mom so my uncle
says my uncle says what you know what
did this guy look like whatever like
that but he knows where to go he knows
where the chop shop is for the purses
so i said so you know she says oh you
know you look like this this and this
he goes i think i think i may know
what's going on here
he goes do me a favor don't call the
cops i think i can handle this
whoa this is all swear to god true so
then
we is this the guy who used to rip your
heart out of your chest from temple of
doom no that's uncle johnny this is this
is t.o
because he's a different guy it would be
great if he went down to the we'll take
and start ripping off
but uncle but uncle johnny did still
have his his his uh
his uniform from korea that had holes
and blood in it
and he said this is what real men do and
then he showed me his bloody uniform i
was like
you know it's okay i know i was like i
was like i i was like i want to put on
your daughter's makeup
you know so so so he says you know don't
you know just
i'll uh i'll take care of this so maybe
an hour to go by
right he comes back with the purse he
has the purse
he said listen the money is already gone
i couldn't get the money back but you
don't have to cancel your credit cards
or your license or whatever
i have the purse back and then they're
like oh my god what happened you know
whatever all this and he's like ah you
know i got the purse back i knew who
who did it so fine whatever he gets the
purse back
okay so many questions he gets the purse
back
then i don't i just forget about this
incident
for you know years fast forward i'm like
late teens or early 20s my uncle victor
they're talking about something they're
like oh remember that time
when somebody stole you know my mother's
purse
you know that guy really got what was
coming to him so i was like what do you
mean what's coming to him like i never
heard of it i thought you just got the
purse back like what happened he goes
well what happened was
is i went to the bodega
knew digital anti-justice yeah he goes i
went to the bodega
he goes i knew who had stolen the purse
he goes he wasn't there because he just
was dropping the purse off
he says i to get the stolen goods back
he said listen i know the woman whose
purse she stole it's going to be really
bad she knows that things are going on
back here
so just give me the purse you know i'll
take care of everything else but just
give me the purse i'll give it back to
he didn't say it was his
is his sister-in-law or anything like
that so he gets the first back
that night i had no idea he went and got
drunk with the guy
who stole my mother's purse he was sure
of gets him drunk he
takes him to our garage which was
detached from our house
he my uncle was a welder and worked with
tools
tied him up in our garage for two days
and melted the skin off his kneecaps
with his welding blowtorch
how have you never told me this story
how you never told me this story what
are you talking about
he blew did i tell you this you just
implicated your uncles to go to jail
he's dead you're uncle's standing i told
you he died
oh my god all right i forgot about that
yeah
he died he died of cancer he said no
meds i'm going out
why wouldn't he take advantage of
medical uh advancements
because he he's ripping guys he's
[ __ ] hitting
his skin your uncle had that in him
yes he in his dna he could melt
someone's knees this is what i'm saying
he said he and that's why i brought it
up because he said to him
you the wrong guy with the wrong family
what about a punch in the mouth nope he
said what
happened to a good shot in the chops he
had to make a statement
he welded his knees off skin off his
kneecaps
what's amazing to me is the fact that he
then called the guy
and asked it like this was a whole sting
operation he went basically
undercover he called this guy and said
let's go hang out yes
and then got the guy drunk brought him
back to your garage i
i need to go over this a little bit more
broad and magical
tied him up and then welded his kneecaps
yep
what well what took the heat from you
told you this when you were
like late like 15 years ago what was
your reaction
to your uncle the moment he told did
your mother know this
no does she know it now no she does she
doesn't know before you
just said this right now yeah is she i
don't think so is she going to be taken
aback in a way that is
serious uh potentially i can't say
enough about the buffy comforter my
girlfriend's pregnant right now
she literally she this is her third
child she's saying
that this pregnancy is getting easier
and easier every day
since we got the buffy um dude i'm
telling you she used to night sweat
you have to understand how much used to
knights went i mean it would be like
literally somebody took her in the
middle and i threw in her pool and then
put her back in the bed
no more night sweats because the breeze
buffy
regulates the temperature and for all
you vegans out there
it's a 100 plant-based design wow
it's made of eucalyptus fabric inside
and out it's softer than cotton
it naturally suits the skin it's earth
friendly it's hypoallergenic
it's cruelty free it brings i'm telling
you this is crazy
eucalyptus debris don't let it near a
koala bear
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free not sell because i haven't sent
to one yet they're sending it to me
if you don't love it you return it at no
cost
let me tell you something right freaking
now buffy if you're just going to scroll
down a little bit
buffy is one of those things where i'm
telling you
it got sent to the house at first i was
like what is this the buffy because
you're thinking buffy the vampire slayer
you're thinking
what does buffy mean and then it it's
this beautiful bedding
i put it down i took a three-hour nap my
kid was walking around the house my
five-year-old
she turned on the oven i had no idea
because i'm asleep on the back are you
serious sleep on the buffy i go to buffy
chickens at first
right nope from my old neighborhood okay
here we go if you go to buffy dot co
because listen to me a company like
buffy doesn't have time to put the n
m in yeah it's buffy dot co c o and you
enter hey babe
that's h-e-y-b-a-b you ready for this
yeah
twenty dollars off twenty dollars for a
spanish speaking audience
vente dollars yeah that's it andrew
jackson
buffy dot co without the m buffy dot co
enter hey babe
h e y b a b e twenty dollars off it's
unbelievable sal doesn't know what i'm
talking about cause he didn't get the
buffy
i did you know that i take vitamins out
the yin yang
right i take so many vitamins and i'm
always switching vitamins because i'm a
lot of times i'm not happy with some of
them right
well now we have a new uh vitamin
sponsoring the show i'm super excited
right you've had it and you really like
it's called ritual it's called ritual
and i really really like it it's been
one of those things where i've been
taking them first of all they have no
color so it's like they're like
you know no like additive color stuff
right so i like that a lot the only
thing though
is i was i was thinking i don't know the
answer to this maybe tell me that i was
thinking like
this thing is great ritual but it
probably has sugars and gmos and major
allergens
shut your mouth kiss yourself jump back
what james brown said it has none of
that stuff
none of that swear to god i wouldn't lie
to you i'm sitting right here with you i
wouldn't lie to these faces
so it doesn't have any of that no it has
none of that wow
you got to believe me you got to believe
me and here's the thing if i go to
ritual.com yeah youth prison promo code
hey babe
ritual.com promo code hey baby get 10
off but not really for that long
well let me just stop you right there
because actually it's ritual.com
slash hey babe right i don't even know
if they have a promo code
it's just ritual they might if they
don't don't just go to ritual.com
and you can begin getting 10 off for the
first three months
three months you could cancel any time
you could pause the subscription
subscription anytime
that's another fun thing it's not like
oh you got a pen a letter with ink
calligraphy on nice card stock and you
got to mail it out some people
they really have they make you jump
hurdles to cancel this should cancel at
a moment's notice you can pause if you
want
try it out see if you like it you know
you don't have to
so my admit it like that three months
that's a full trimester my girlfriend's
pregnant right now by the time the
baby's born i'm still getting ritual
for 10 off as long as i go to ritual.com
hey babe yeah if you got pregnant today
and also went to ritual.com hey babe
today
you would see 10 savings into the
beginning of the second trimester
wow just as the baby's crying and the
bit you can hear comes the size of like
an avocado at that point it becomes
volcano yeah god bless god bless love
afterwards the breasts leak as well the
breasts begin to produce milk
and they start leaking and that's
sometimes even when you're not prepared
for it 100
uh granted you know
we diverted a little bit from ritual but
it is important to know about what's
important
the gestation period and a woman's
health 100 and there's a lot of apps and
things you can do that and
uh go find the answers some of those
questions but i think the way to find
them the quickest and what you
should do for the sharpest mental i've
i've been taking this product and i've
been so sharp mentally and i felt so
good
the only blemish i've had today is i ate
a tuna melt that's not agreeing with me
right now
but i know taking a ritual is going to
make you feel better ritual dot com
slash hey babe ten percent off three
months i don't know what to do with
myself for the rest of today i guess
we'll block his name out just to protect
the
you have to block his we'll block his
aim up but just know that i have an
uncle in my family
who took a welding gun and melted the
skin off this guy's kneecaps who stole
my mother's purse
that's all you need to know kidnapping
and torture yeah but he stole my
mother's purse
true so maybe it's just vigilante
justice which is what i said a little
bit earlier which and the and the
and the the snowflake world we live in
you can't even do stuff like that
anymore i mean
your uncle yeah is you
you had the you had just moments ago you
had the unmitigated goal
yes to compare me to charles manson for
bringing two
aaa batteries in my luggage in case my
remote dies
your uncle said no to meds when he got
cancer yeah then kidnapped a man
tied hog tied him in a garage and melted
off his plastic and then
you call him me a serial killer your
family
you you're you're serial killer adjacent
your uncle's a serial killer he's a
serial killer this and this this is the
same man
who melted melted skin off kneecaps uh
didn't take cancer meds but also
built us from scratch a carousel in our
backyard that little kids would come
over he
took crates from outside the bodega that
the guys used to sit on cut holes in
them
made a whole mechanism that spun us
around me and all our little kid
neighbors he made us a full carousel in
the backyard i swear to god
then he also made a hot dog cart out of
nowhere from just the tools he had in
his garage and would ride us around and
we would sell hot dogs from his homemade
hot dog cart
then he made a a contraption that
separated somehow
grease from the floor in the hospital
and grease from
the floor in a burning building the fire
department bought the patent off him he
charged them no money
he could have been a multi-millionaire
he could have been a multi-millionaire
and he said no i just want to give back
he this man was he
was he a savant was he like an idiot
savant he was one of those guys
his english wasn't great he was born and
raised he was patented
i swear he but he didn't patent it he
just let the fire department buy it and
he didn't
he didn't do it he didn't care he just
was like he was a man of being care he's
a man of principle okay we need to know
right now we're asking the viewers to
hashtag this
is this guy a hero or a villain i need
to know because
the more you speak it gets more gray for
me speaking of gray
my hair good okay no but i can't even
move on from this just yet
yeah i mean did you ever take yourself
in your mind
to the actual moment that your uncle
lived out in his garage like did you
ever put yourself in your uncle's shoes
and say to yourself this is what this
man had to carry out am i capable of
that what was that scene actually like
if i was hiding
in like a you know in like a tool shed
in there
in the garage and peeking could i have
watched this this is like
you understand when someone's tied up
and you turn on a torch
and then put it at someone's knees and
melt their skin off
yeah like we're making light of it it
was a long time ago what have you
but that is a moment right that is a
very very
it's heavy very heavy and i'm almost
positive looking back chronologically at
when this happened when i was eight or
nine years old in the summer
of you know like 1992-ish i'm almost
positive in that same summer it may have
may have even been in that same week
that he melted somebody's skin off their
kneecaps and then let them go and told
them don't come back here is when he
made also made the carousel for us
so i think for sure this is
overcompensating the same garage that
had
melted flesh on the floor it's where he
built the carousel that is one thousand
percent
of the crates half of your childhood
memories are tied directly to bodegas
no no dude the bojek for me but i lived
my life in and out of the bodega that's
what i would get my school lunch
we would get to we'd do the grocery
shopping i used to go to the
to the uh you know supermarket or
whatever and just go to the bodega
so all the toilet paper the paper towels
all that stuff both bodega it was right
on my corner do people know what a
bodega is that there aren't
if you're not from new york city and you
don't know what a boat or east coast a
bodega
is a deli on the corner but they not
only have sandwiches and sodas and
drinks they also have household
appliances
you can uh you know a lot of times they
have a really not good uh deli counter
yeah they have a really bad 24 hours you
go in there get cat food
band-aids yeah and and and a meat patty
and a meat patty
and a you know turkey and cheese
sandwich 40 ounces 40 ounces yeah
they'll some
you know now there's always an ice cream
fridge
you could buy chip witches and ice cream
pops and all that
potato chips pretzels potato chips
bagels bagels batteries gum
chocolate candy yeah you could buy
supplements at the campus
you could condiment condiments condoms
cigarettes
you could buy you could buy the the the
little apple pies that they have the
little coffee talk apple pies but then
you can also
buy you know you could buy uh tide yeah
you could buy tide to wash your clothes
paper towels detergents
solutions the deli yes sometimes you
could buy frozen foods there
you could play the lotto tin foil gamble
you can run you can run illegal gambling
rings out of the back of them you could
do that you could yeah you're going to
get
just that's the place to take purses
that have been stolen all
usually owned operated and ran with one
to two employees
three max usually from puerto rico
dominican republic
running this entire 24 7 365. 24 7 365
no days off
with a cat perusing in and out of the
aisles
wherever you go there's a bodega cat and
there are always there is
always one of their friends drinking one
of the inventory beers
at somewhere in the store 100 either
inside or outside somebody's drinking a
beer
the history of new york city bodegas the
name bodega originates
from the spanish word which can mean
storeroom
wine cellar or grocery store because
these shops first started popping up in
the 1940s and 50s in hispanic
communities
new yorkers as a whole took to the idea
and these small shops multiplied
i i literally think being a part of a
bodega community
helped shape me for the better bodegas
are just it was the great
kiss for my first girl one of my first
girlfriends in a bodega in that bodega
wow a lot of stuff went down but is it
still all is this still
still around but they just changed
owners we should do it we should do a
fraud
we're taking a day trip to the bodega
taking where people were people
where crime went down and people were
tortured for it that's 100
yes i can't believe i forgot to add this
not only is it still around
a year ago right before the pandemic
when they were changing owners
they asked me to pay for my uncle's tab
which is
from dead while he was dead because they
were like they're
closing out their books and they had all
these tabs but he's dead yeah no i know
but they still he's still
oh my god they had his tab after he died
they see me like i gotta break some news
to you guys and he died like six or
seven years ago
i swear to god i wish i had a picture of
this i swear to god they had it written
on a piece of paper
that was this must have been the same
piece of paper from the night he was all
yellow and saying all his things
from like 1991 to 2019 his entire tab
three hundred dollars no way in 20 years
all here to pay was 300
and he was clear that's how cheap things
are in the bodega
he just poured a waters in the bodega
quarter waters
20 years of just quarter drinks 25 cent
quart of water that's it
yeah that you would open them up with
your teeth and it was just how much
sugar
if i just it's 100 if i'm logging in a
quart of water
to my fitness pal today what am i in for
300 i think you're in for a couple well
they're they're probably the quarter
waters probably six ounces
yeah i call them quarter drinks it's
it's it's straight up high fructose corn
it's a combination if you're not from
from the us or the east coast you don't
know what we're saying when we
quarter water it's a combination of
water food coloring sugar and sugar sold
as a drink in small plastic bottles for
25 cents quite possibly the worst thing
for your body
and the environment yeah there was
straight up plastic there wasn't even a
cap you just
yeah you plunged your finger through a
piece of foil on top you were like
oh you peeled it i would do it myself
get it i would open it up on my teeth i
would
and then would you peel the whole thing
off or would you tuck it in all around
the sides i would bite on my teeth and
then i'd suck out the juice
those member mondo ice pops bondo is the
other thing and then i don't know if you
had this
we used to have the ice tea in the milk
cartons we used to call them bushwick
snapples
because bushwick was the bad area so we
would say these this is like you know
snapple's a dollar but this
iced tea and a milk carton is 50 cents
we call it a bushwick snapple yeah and
it would give you instant diarrhea into
diarrhea well what happened was
snapple got uh got you know all like oh
we're going up to two bucks for a glass
now yeah and they went from 20 ounce
bottles to 16 ounce bottles right and
arizona was like
hold the presses i'm gonna give you a 24
ounce can for 99 cents
i'm gonna stamp that right on the can so
nobody can do any funny business right
so this is gonna be
24 ounces for 99 cents and they came in
and they took a lot of
snapple remember the snap lady do you
remember the snap oh yeah
wendy what was her name the snapple
wendy if you could do an interview you
could only do one interview would you do
it with the snapple lady
yolanda vega or the dunkin donuts
munchkin time to make the donuts guy or
the micro machines guy who would talk
about it
micro machines is the snapple lady still
with us
wendy kaufman is wendy kaufman still
with us i love wendy kaufman
she was just she's just an actress that
got the they got the role of the lady
what a gig born in 1958 in woodmere nice
nice
long island girl yes 62 years old good
for her good i wonder if she really
dude do you know that the guy is she's
sick of snapple she might be sick of
snapchat think of it she probably never
even ever says
the verizon guy's sick of verizon he
works for sprint now that's right do you
know this
you know the guy the aol guy you've got
mail yeah you know like you know that
guy's story
no are you ready for this yes i was
doing a road date
half sold road date a couple years ago
in cleveland
i'm doing daytime talk show
in cleveland it's 8 o'clock in the
morning the camera guy
the cameraman working for the his name
is elwood edwards
the cameraman who was working for the
local cleveland
news affiliate is the aol you've got
male guy
his wife was working for aol in the
early 90s or whatever
she said oh we're trying to come up with
a thing for aol mail like a little voice
thing and he said i'll do it
puts his voice in a concept cassette
tape you've got mail gives it to him
didn't get
a penny come on google elwood edwards
works for cleveland local news
come on aol it says he's an uber driver
now he's an uber driver but you got to
be kidding me you gotta you can't give
this guy a little bit of money i believe
it dude not a not a penny i was like in
cleveland he said yeah so
there's a couple things we need to do
yeah i need to do hashtag
hey babe hero or hashtag hey babe
villain
okay as far as how you perceive his
uncle is he a hero
or a villain right hey babe villain
hey babe hero right okay another thing
hashtag
hey babe aol how about giving elwood
edwards some of the money that's coming
to him yes
hashtag hashtag yeah so do you guys know
that big j
uh auditioned for the verizon guy big j
christian did
yeah i didn't even know him like the
actual verizon guy he was supposed to be
it and i i don't know he didn't get it
and he realized
he always hate watches that i had no how
did i not know that
i didn't know that there's a lot of
things you don't know about your friends
i know a lot of things we don't know
about you
that's right i'll tell you no i don't
know you're stacking batteries birth
control off control
um okay so i still can't get over your
uncle so did you what was your mom's so
your mom doesn't know
i would love to film a reaction video
can we patreon
patreon a reaction video to your mom
watching this segment and finding out
that your uncle is a tor that your uncle
was a torturer my mother my mother's
probably the type person she wouldn't
even believe it she said no you're
making that up for a fact that's not
true
and and unfortunately you can't take a
great result that's a great reaction
anyway we can't talk to myself she
brushes it off
not with us yeah do you think a purse
would have a stolen again
do you think that guy ever stole the
purse again i if i'm being honest with
you i think that man probably left
the country immediately because all the
break-in all the
robberies stopped wow they all stopped
dude how about
just real quick his his um his daughter
go faster please oh yeah sorry he's his
joyner yeah
who is is great great great person
cousin mike great great great
uh somebody tried to break into the
house somebody tried to break
what did she do what did she do did she
wear this skin like
like a costume no how about this
somebody tried to break their house we
were maybe 18 19 years old
i'm coming down the block i'm coming
down the block with a sandwich i'll
never forget from the delinquent corner
called fetchers
shout out fetchers also a great bodega
cat one time he threw up on my sandwich
and i didn't realize until i had already
eaten cat vomit
but whatever fetch is great great place
i'm coming down with sandwiches or my
lunch from fetchers i see police in a
fire truck outside my house
i start sprinting i don't know what's
going on i see a man because the way our
uh uh
house was set up where this one of the
side windows led into our
driveway i see a man laying down
with what looks like two broken arms in
the driveway
and i said what is like what's going on
i go up there my cousin says
somebody just tried to break into the
house i threw him out the window so
somebody tried to break the house he
broke both of his arms on the land
was being arrested was being like
handcuffed with two broken arms
screaming in pain
my arms are broken because he had just
tried to break into our family's home
and my cousin who was 18 or 19 year old
girl at the time
threw him out the window so so sometimes
it's so hard for me because you know
especially like moving forward in the
world and
progressive and all that stuff sometimes
when i hear like even like
you know on the news or like oh this
woman felt uncomfortable
around a man or whatever and you know
you feel for all that but the family i
come from like my cousin was throwing
burglars out the window wow
so sometimes i'm like i don't know like
is my cousin too crazy is my cousin too
hard or are they too soft what's the
happy medium yeah that's like that's
you know that's why you know what else i
like the word burglar i like oh like
i mentioned before dungarees i bet you
half of our listeners don't know what a
dungaree is they don't know what
or a vestibule i like saying that over
the hallway you got a great vestibule
yeah i got a nice foyer yeah
i've never stopped saying it because
it's so much more fun than jean
or denim one of the best dungaree best
times you can have is wearing dungarees
eating dunkaroos inside of a dunkin
donuts
that's a great thing i say it all the
time i'll go into a store be like where
where are your dungarees you know what's
unfortunate about the dungaree
right is it's probably going to go out
of style because of athleisure i mean
how much more comfy waffy are we wearing
athleisure than we are dungarees i mean
we're both wearing dungarees now and
mike tyson sweatshirts yeah
but i feel like the athleisure huge huge
market share
we had we covered this in the previous
episode but i'm surprised if you guys
after home alone ever set up stuff for
potential robbers
interesting well because speaking of
home alone
yes and that's another reason why i'm
not packing all these things because i
don't want it to be like i'm freaking
kevin mcallister with all these bags
looking for my family and kids i'm like
we all have we're all traveling with
backpacks so i don't get kevin
mcallister
kevin mcallister never made us at the
airport he didn't carry on picks he made
it to the airport in
home alone two which is another good
season home on two was an okay sequel
homo 3 suck humble on three should be
erased i'm sorry
i'm sorry to everybody involved nobody
needed it nobody wanted it it didn't do
a good and you know what i know everyone
was well intentioned hundred percent
i'm not really coming down on you we all
make stuff that sucks yeah
but that was an ill-conceived that was
an ill-conceived sequel yeah home alone
two home alone two
i i i homo 2 was more of what we loved
but he got a little bit older so i
felt a little bit less in love with him
right and then also i love
somebody clipped that exact statement
take that out of context clip it
you can make t-shirts yeah yeah yeah
but um you know if i was a developer a
robber or a thief i'd insist to be
called a burglar
yeah burger sounds more romantic i feel
like a burglar's reserved
for more of a high-end criminal like a a
jewel well i guess that's a jewel thief
but a jewel burglar a jewel burglar
yeah i'm a cat a cat a cat burglar my
house is burned
yeah my house was burglarized yeah cause
it's like you know you want someone to
be in like black and white pinstripes
burglar sounds less offensive and more
of an art form right like i could say to
you
you know i'm a i'm a professional
burglar yeah and you'd be like whoa
whoa uh tell me about it if i tell you
like
rob house is bro you'd be like this guy
don't want to get mixed up with him
but if i go if i'm a burglar you'd be
like oh a nice guy burglar
listen yeah yeah he's a burglar burglar
versus thief first robber so what
what are you saying well burglar versus
steve first robber it's all the same
stuff
i mean i guess it says a burglar is
someone who steals by breaking into
entering illegally a building for
example someone's home
a thief is someone who steals something
without being noticed for example a
pickpocket
so you have to break so it has to be a
breaking and entering to be a burglar
so it's deep is a thief is probably not
even as
serious as a burglar gypsies tramps and
thieves that's more and more forgivable
you know right
thieves yeah yeah burglar i've never
been
i've never i don't think i've ever had
anyone steal anything from me
babe i okay i used to bartend right
right so i used to have very weird hours
i used to get home at like four
five in the morning probably home
sometimes by five
not in bed till like six right right
that was my regulations have a snack and
go to bed or we just go right to bed i
always had a snack and it was a lot of
times it was the same exact snack which
was i remember for like six months i
got the same exact thing i used to go to
m m bagels i just get everything bagel
with cream cheese
i used to get the cupcakes with the the
thing
oh the um hostess the hostess cupcakes
yeah swirl with with the cream in the
middle and
and uh and a and a pint of tropicana and
that's what you would go to bed on
yeah yeah oh man yeah yeah that was like
my favorite right
i mean i didn't do it every day but that
was like when i was like when i worked
till five and i was like
defeated i was like i'm going i'm going
i think but you'd have a nice sleep with
that yeah but that was like four
thousand we talked about this earlier
like
if you don't really care to get
knowledgeable about calories
yeah and you don't realize what you're
putting in that's like that's like
that's like no joke like probably like
2500 calories
at six in the morning right before i'm
going to bed right before you go to bed
and then sleep and then wake up and
probably the first thing you'll do is
eat and wake up so you
before you even start your day that day
you're probably
at 4 000 calories right
it's all sugar and carbs right all sugar
right orange juice cupcakes and and
bagel oh my
god terrible terrible just like i was
going to say before if you drink a
quarter drink every single day
for like you'll die at like age thirty a
hundred percent yeah a thousand percent
it's like it's like acceptable poison
it's poison
no there's no brand names it's just
coming out of it somewhere for you know
yeah
shooting different colors into poison
yeah it's poison that's all it is
and we feed it to children like as an
adult you don't have it anymore well
that's just poison for children well
that's the thing with sugar that's thing
with sugar like there's a big story it's
sugar or like
rewarding people with sugar like i think
it's one of those things like how like
they used to be commercials for
cigarettes
and oh i think sugar is going to be a
thing that we look back at like why are
we giving our children that
like you're giving them you're giving
them a thing that's going to cause
health
poison yeah you're giving them poison
they said it's worse than salt
but what's better than a butterfinger
nothing can you let everybody get your
fingers called conundrum
yeah yeah so wait so what happened so
you come up at 6am i used to i used to
get up at like one
right so i come home i go to bed i'm in
bed
business is huge by the way you you
don't understand how bad i have to pee
right now it's actually like
indescribable but i'm just gonna keep
drinking the water do you want to
do like editing magic go pee and come
back i've committed this to you
yeah i i'm here with you great i'm
listening no problem i'm in the zone
i'll try to get this story done no i
want you to take my time okay that's it
okay
um i'm sleeping right so i hear oh i
hear
i used to have black out shades and
everything because like i couldn't
since i was getting going to bed when
the sun was coming up i need to black
everything
so i black out i mean i'm in the black
and i hear black out matters
yeah i jump up and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is that right
so it's pitch black i get up i'm
stumbling to the door and i go
hello and i hear my landlord upstairs he
goes
salads dan open the door he was a new
york city detective and he was like a
big guy
right we were good friends he was like a
cool dude and i was like what i
i cracked the door and i go and like the
sun comes in i'm
in straight up pajamas you have pajamas
to bed
no ever no but i do i sleep on my boxers
i never wear pajamas i did boxers and
and a t-shirt in my life then i did
boxers and like pajama pants and a
t-shirt
but i got to tell you pajama well at
least a pajama pant
yeah it what it does is it puts you in
the mood for bed or for comfort yeah
it's it's a my thing in your mind i
throw on a pair of my pajama pants yeah
when i'm like
nearing bedtime yeah and my whole mood
shifts
yeah my dad my daughter just a week or
two ago
she was wearing pajamas and she asked me
she's like why don't you wear pajamas i
was like pajamas are you know
really kids just wear pajamas and she
said you don't know how to have fun and
then she went to bed who did that my
daughter my
daughter said you don't know how to have
fun sometimes during a holiday
or a particularly chilly night maybe in
the winter i'll also throw on a pajama
top
wow i feel like twas the night before
christmas i feel like that guy yeah
but but it's it's fun it's cozy i'm all
about cozy no you're the most
you're one of the guy you're one of my
friends who's about comfort the most i
would say you're like
you about that comfort life i'm about it
more than anybody else i've ever been
about that comfortable
without that comfort life yeah t-shirt
there you go
so go ahead then we also have to talk
about the gray hair that's right
or we can do it on patreon yeah coming
soon
i crack it comes and i go i literally
had like i probably had like spittle i
had my hair
i remember the pajamas i was wearing i
was actually wearing corona pajama pants
they were 100 yellow with like the
corona logo all over them i was going to
say you could see
you saw into the future yeah i got it
i got i remember i got them at models
yeah which rip models closed down
it's all closed bankrupt right models
that that's more and that's an east
coast uh
sports apparel store yeah that's that
was like yankees all the way that's the
yankees all the way
i feel like they were ingrained in like
always them and oots or chips
and w b mason all the yankees let me ask
you a question
who but wb mason i don't know that was
their slogan
who who who wb mason uh i can't think of
anybody else is it a good slogan because
we still remember it or a bad slogan
because i never knew what they meant
i was gonna say i can't tell you to this
day what w mason even does
what kind of paper products what kind of
company is it i don't have any idea who
are you gonna get your paper products
from and that's a weird slogan because
like there's so many people to get paper
products
i know i'm like a staple you can just
get paper products on like a hundred
different people yeah
but i guess who but you guys a little
bit yeah office supplies office supply
who but w mason it's like okay officemax
staples like yeah
yeah the bodega yeah just the section in
target like yeah
it is oh shout out to mason so
so by the way pajamas just real quick
while you talk about this when did start
where everything else starts
india in the 18th and 19th century
british influence on the wide western
world during the victorian era
it was uh the worldwide use of the word
pajamas
um uh was was from india
pajamas were first introduced in britain
in the 17th century originally known as
moguls breaches
but they only became popular as
loungewear for men from about 1870. so
from now on we will call them my moguls
breaches
breaches yeah i'm getting tired it was a
long day i'm going to throw all my
moguls breeches in the head
well you deserve it you're the mogul so
pajamas have only been around for 150
years that's it dude
what were people wearing for pajamas
before pajamas i guess you just
we're just going to bed and kelp maybe
they would just go to bed like a burlap
sack
this is one of my softer sacks yeah they
bought naked well no before they
because i when i think of old school
pajamas like they got the hat on what
about the pajama hat how stupid
that seems unnecessary why would you
have the pajama cap are they sleeping in
the cap or is the cap just a matching
accoutrement for when you're walking
around traipsing around the house with
the gown on
i think that it's gotta be just for
walking around
oh here we go they were originally worn
by men and women to protect against cold
nighttime temperatures
men may also have worn them to cover
their bald heads in the name of dignity
you don't have to cover your bald heads
anymore keeps.com promo code hey babe
that's it
today sleeping caps aren't commonly worn
by men and many women choose to wear a
sleeping cap for hair health
rather than warmth or fashion i've never
seen a man in my life
man or woman wearing a sleeping cap all
right that's uh hey babe sleeping caps
merch so is that what i'll do knock it
down sleeping caps yep hey babe sleeping
i'd love people to start you know what
it is uh i think that's when maybe they
didn't have heat
right you know because they say this is
big the top of your head is big for
for temperature escaping and everything
yes so that i get that but
at this moment in time i wouldn't want
to sleep with a sleeping car by the way
i think i probably know the answer this
but i guess people would just also in
the middle of night just have to sleep
with a bucket next to them
imagine being diabetic in the 1700s
you're gonna go to the outhouse and
maybe get killed by a bear
or a random enemy going through the
lands just to take a piss right
probably just would pee or [ __ ] in a
bucket in the middle of the night right
wow yeah this has been hey babe
yeah i mean yeah we're over right now
but it doesn't matter the story about
them
let's go can we start doing more that's
on the ground
we just just randomly and then whenever
one of us says it we gotta stop
we gotta get out of the episode we'll
pick it up in the next episode
you want what do you think pip it's a
cliffhanger it's our first ever
cliffhanger
let's do it we're gonna that story's
gonna be picked up on the next step so
i'm dead asleep
it's pitch black it's pitch black i went
to bed at six in the morning i'm in
corona pajamas i
stumbled to the door i knocked over a
couple things i cracked it i said
hello and he goes salads dan open the
door
dan is my name upstairs landlord he's a
new york city detective and i heard boom
boom boom boom boom and i didn't know
what was going on
this has been hey babe yeah every
thursday 11 a.m eastern time
patreon coming soon you can check me out
on my other podcast chrissy kaos
uh youtube.com all christycomedy.com for
all my dates appreciate all the support
and love
salvocanocomedy.com other other podcasts
on this network it's called tastebuds
check it out no pressure network that's
what we're about the no press network
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babes hey babe